Thanks d dot.
So I'm,
I'm punching and uh,
um,
like the,
also adds a Google Cambridge office and
uh,
I'm one of the authors of tensorflow.
So we're going to change topic and talk
about tensorflow.
So,
um,
I read your course material a little bit
and I gathered as you all use tensorflow
in previous parts of the lecture.
Is that right?
Great.
Okay.
So my focus will be how to more
efficiently,
right,
and debulk it,
machine learning models in tensorflow.
So the question is whether you need to
debug a machine learning model.
I think the answer is yes,
of course machine learning models are
very different from traditional
programs,
but their software and their code and
the software and they will have bugs and
the,
you need to debug your models from time
to time.
So hopefully after this lecture you will
know a little bit more about how to more
efficiently devalue our machine learning
models in tensorflow.
So before we dive into debugging,
I want to talk about how machine
learning models are represented in,
in the computer because that turns out
to be important for how you write and
develop programs.
So there are two ways in which a machine
learning model can be represented.
So it's either a data structure or
program.
So if it's a data structure,
then when you write code to,
for example,
define a layer of neural network,
you're actually building our graph and
those lines of code,
when they're executed,
they don't actually do the competition,
they're just building the graph and the
graph needs to be fed into some kind of
machinery because I'm kind of execution
engine to actually run the model.
And the second way in which you can
define a machine and the motto is to
write it as a program.
So that's more straightforward.
So those kinds of lines of code will
actually do the competition on either
the CPU or Gpu depending on whether you
have a gpu or not.
Um,
so the first paradigm is also called
symbolic execution or different
execution.
And the second one is also called I'm
eager,
execution or imperative execution.
So I'm now the question for you is
whether tensorflow is the first paradigm
or the Second Paradigm?
So I heard someone said first,
second,
both.
Yeah.
So I think it's a trick question,
right?
So the answer is both.
So if you ask the question like half a
year ago,
then the answer will be only the first.
But in the latest version of tensorflow,
we support both modes.
Um,
and I'm going to give you some examples
in the following slides.
So by default tends to flow is the first
node,
so that's the classical,
um,
traditional tensorflow style.
So,
um,
just to give you a refresher of how to
use tensorflow to define a simple model,
you import the tensorflow stf and then
you defined some constants or maybe some
variables as inputs.
And then you write a line to say like,
you want to multiply x and w and then
you want to add the results of the
multiple patient to,
um,
to another thing be right.
So you can think of this as a very
simple linear regression model,
if you will.
Now,
the important thing here is when this
line is executed,
it's actually not doing the computation.
So the multiplication will not happen at
this point.
If we print the results of this line,
why?
Then you will see it's not 40,
it's not 10 times four equals 40.
Instead it's like,
um,
it's like a abstract symbolic thing.
So it's called a tenser and it knows
what kind of operation it needs to do
when it's actually executed in the
future.
So mall is that operation.
It also needs an information about it
also knows information about like what
dependencies are,
which are x and w in this case,
but it's not shown in the printed
message here.
And likewise,
when you do Tfa ad,
when that line of code is executed,
the addition will not happen.
It's going to happen later.
So by later,
I mean a case,
uh,
the points at which you create a session
by calling tf that session.
And when you have that session is
created,
it will basically automatically pull in
the graph.
You have not already built in the
previous lines of code and then you tell
the session like which tensor,
which abstract symbol in the graph you
want to execute,
and then it's going to basically analyze
the structure of the graph,
sort out all the dependencies and topple
logically execute other nodes in the
graph to do the multiplication first and
then do the audition next and it's going
to give you the final results,
which is 42 so it can think of tfs
session as a Ng.
So it's going to run the model on CPU.
If you only have a CPU,
it's going to run the model on Gpu if
you have
GPU.
Now obviously I'm this paradigm of
defining our model is not the most
straightforward because those lines of
codes that looked like doing competition
is not doing any actual competition.
And you need to learn a new api called
TF session.
So why does tensorflow do it this way?
So obviously it's because there are some
advantages you can get.
So the first advantage is because the
model is a data structure,
it's relatively easy to serialize this.
Um,
and then these airlines,
there's somewhere else you can train a
model and then you can load your model
onto some kind of other devices like
mobile devices or embedded devices like
raspberry pie or a car or robots and you
can also,
um,
sterilize the motto and then load the
model on like a faster hardware like
Google's tpu.
Um,
so these things are hard,
hard to do if your model is a python
right,
if your model is a python program
because those devices may not have
python and running them.
And even if those devices have python
running on,
on them,
that's probably not what you want to use
because python is slow sometimes.
So I have those links here in the slide.
So I'm going to send those slides to the
course organizers and you can click on
those links if you're interested in any
of those topics like deployments on
mobile devices and so on.
So the next advantage is because your
model is a data structure,
you are not tied down to the language in
which the model is defined.
So nowadays,
most machine learning models are written
in python,
but maybe your application server or
maybe a web server is running Java or c
plus plus and you don't want to rewrite
the whole stack in python just to be
able to add some machine learning to
your stack,
right?
So,
um,
if a model is a data structure that you
can save the model after training and
they can load it into Java or c plus
plus or c sharp or any of the supported
languages and that you will be ready to
serve the trained model from your web
server or application server.
And the other nice thing about
representing data as the model,
as a data structure,
as you can distribute the model very
easily onto a number of machines called
workers.
And those workers will basically use the
same graph.
They're going to do the exact same
competition,
but they are going to do it on different
slices of the training later.
So this kind of training in a
distributed way,
it's very important for cases in which
you need to treat them out.
I'm a very large amounts of data
quickly.
I'm the kind of problem that's Google,
sometimes it has to deal with.
So um,
of course you have to start to modify
your model graph so that the shared
things like the weights variables in the
model are shared on a server called
primary receiver here,
but that's basically distributed
training intensive flow in a nutshell.
So again,
if you're interested,
you can look at the slide and can click
that link to learn more about
distributor training.
Any questions so far?
Okay.
So,
um,
also because you're representing your
model as a data structure,
you're not limited by the speed on
concurrency of the language in which the
model is defined.
We know that on python is slow sometimes
and even if you try to make python or
parallel parallel as the by writing
multithreading,
you will run into the show called python
global interpreter lock and that will
slow you down,
especially for the kind of,
um,
competition.
Got a deep learning model needs to do.
Um,
so the way in which we solve this
problem in symbolic execution is by
sending the model as a data structure
from the layer of python c plus plus.
So there,
um,
at the level of c plus plus you can use
true concurrency,
you can fully parallel buys things and
that can benefit the speed of the model.
So obviously,
um,
there are all those advantages,
but there are also,
there was like,
um,
shortcomings of symbolic execution,
for example.
It's less intuitive,
it's harder to learn.
Um,
so you,
you need to spend some time getting used
to the idea of beauty.
You're defining a model first and then
run the model later with tf dot session.
Um,
and it's harder to debug a way a model
goes around.
That's because everything,
every actual competition happens inside
the TF dot session.
And that's a single line of Python code
calling a c plus plus.
So you can use the usual kinds of python
debugger to do bumped heads.
But I'm going to show you that they were
actually very good tools in tensive flow
that you can use to debug things that
had been in.
Do you have that session?
And uh,
another shortcoming of a symbolic
exclusion is that it's harder to write
control flow structures.
So by that I mean I'm structure as like
I'm looping over a number of things or
if else branches,
so that kind of thing that we encounter
in programming languages,
but some machine learning models also
need to do that,
right?
So likely recurrent neural networks need
to loop over things and some kind of
fancy I'm a dynamic models need to do if
ellis branches and so on.
I'm also going to show some slides to
show those concrete examples.
So it's very hard to sometimes very hard
to write that kind of control flow
structures in symbolic execution,
but it's much easier in eager execution.
So I'm with Eager Execution Europe,
your program can be more authentic and
it's easier to learn and easier to read.
So here's an example.
So on the left you're seeing the same
code as before.
So we are using the default symbolic
execution of tensorflow.
No.
Now how do we switch to the new eager
execution?
So it just add two lines of code.
You import the eager module and then you
call a method called enabled eager
execution,
and you don't have to make any other
changes to your program in this case,
um,
but you will because of these few lines,
you changed the semantics of these two
lines,
multiply and add.
So now instead of building a graph,
this line is actually doing the
multiplication of ten four.
And if you print while,
you will see the value and if you print
the value of z,
you will also see the value.
So everything is,
I'm like a flutter and easier to
understand.
Now,
as I mentioned before,
eager mode also makes it easier to
control flow,
dependency and the dynamic models.
So here's an example.
So suppose you want to write a recurrent
neural network,
which I think you have seen in previous
parts of the lecture before,
in,
um,
in the default mode of tensorflow.
Here's about the amount of code you need
to write.
So,
um,
you cannot use the default native
foreloop or while loop in python.
You have to use the tensorflow's special
wild loop.
And in order to use it,
you have to define two functions,
one for the termination,
conditioner of the loop and one for the
body of the loop.
And then you need to feed those two
functions into the while loop and get
answers back.
And remember,
those sensors are not actual values.
You have to send those 10 stairs into
session that runs,
get together actual value.
So there are a few hoops to jump through
if you want to write a rn and from
scratch in the default mode of
tensorflow,
but with eager execution that things
becomes much simpler.
So you can use the native for loop in
Python to loop over time steps and the
input and you don't have to worry about
those symbolic tensors or sessions are
run the,
the,
um,
the variables you get from this followup
is the result of the competition.
So I'm eager mode makes it much easier
to write the so called dynamic models.
So what do we mean by static models in
the dynamic models?
So by static models we mean models who
was structured don't change with the
input data.
And I think you have seen examples like
that in the image model sections of this
lecture.
So the diagram here shows the inception
model in tensorflow,
so the model can be very complicated,
can have hundreds of layers and the can
do,
can do like a complicated competition
like convolution pooling and a dense
manipulation and so on.
But the structure of the model is always
the same no matter how the image
changes,
the image always has the same size and
the same cutter depth.
Um,
but the model will always compute the
same.
I mean it will always do the same
competition regardless how the image
changes.
So that's what we mean by static model.
But there are also models was structured
change with inputs and data.
So the recurrence,
do you want network?
We have seen is actually an example of
that.
And the reason why it's changes is
because it needs to loop over things.
So in the simplest kind of recurrent
neural network,
it will loop over items in the sequence,
like a words in a sentence.
So you can say that the length of the
model is proportional to the length of
the input sentence,
but there are also more complicated
changes of the model structure with
input data.
So some of the state of the art models
that deal with natural language,
we actually take a parse tree of a
sentence as the inputs and the structure
of the model will reflect that tree.
So,
um,
as we have seen before,
it's complicated to your rights are wild
loops or control flow structures in,
um,
in those defaults symbolic mode.
Now if you want one to ride that kind of
model,
it gets even more complicated because
there you will need to nest on
conditional branches and a wild loops,
but it's much easier to revise in that
moment because you can just use the
native for loops and while loops and if
statements in python.
So we actually have an example to show
you how to ride that kind of models.
Dads take parse trees as input and the
process natural language.
So please check that out if you want.
You have a question,
right?
The tree is static.
Okay.
Yeah.
The tree is static in this particular
input,
but you can have a longer sentence,
right?
There's the,
the,
the grammar of the sentence.
The sentence can change from one
sentence to another,
right?
So that will make the model structure
change as well.
So basically you can hard code the
structure of the model.
You have to like look how to treat and
then like,
um,
uh,
do some kind of like an if else
statements and while loops in order to
like turn the theory into the model.
Yep.
Okay.
So,
um,
we have seen that the eco mode is very
good for um,
learning and debugging and for writing
control flow structures.
But sometimes you may,
you may still want to debug a tensorflow
programs running in the default symbolic
modes.
And there are a few reasons for that.
First,
you may be using some kind of old code
of tensorflow that hasn't been ported to
eager mode yet.
And some high level API as you might be
using,
like tf learned or terrorists or tf slim
have not been important to.
Yes.
And you may want to stick to the default
symbolic moments.
It because you care about speed on,
because eco mode is sometimes slower
than the default mode.
So,
um,
the good news is that we have a tool
intensive flow that can help you like
debug attentive flow model running in
the tf,
the TF dot session in the mode,
and that's what was called tf dbg,
or tensorflow debugger.
So the way in mentioned you use it is
kind of similar to the way in which he
was eager,
execution,
important and additional module.
And after you have created the session
object,
you,
we'll wrap the session object where the
rapper in this case is called local
command line interface direct GRANDPA.
So,
um,
you don't need to make any other changes
to your code because this rapid object
has the same interface as the unwrapped
object.
But basically you can,
um,
you can think of this as like an
oscilloscope on some kind of instrument
on your tf dot session,
which is otherwise opaque.
So now,
once you have wrapped that session,
when sessions are run is called,
you're going to drop into the command
line interface.
You're going to see basically a
presentation of,
um,
one intermediate tensors are executed in
the sessions are run and the structure
and the graph and so on.
So I encourage you to encourage you to
play with that after the lecture.
So
the TTF debugger is also very useful for
debugging or kind of bugs in your
machine learning models which will
probably occur.
Those are called numerical instability
issues.
So by that I mean sometimes value is in
the network who will become Nan's or
infinities.
So Nan stands,
stands for not a number.
Naza infinities are like bad float
values that will sometimes happen.
Now,
if you don't have a specialized tool in
tensorflow,
it can be difficult to pinpoint the
exact notes which generates the nuns and
infinities,
but the debugger has a special commands
with which you can run the model until
any nodes in the graph contains Nan's or
infinities.
So in our experience,
that happens quite often and the most
common causes of Nancy and infinities
are underflow and overflow.
So for example,
if there's an underflow,
then a number will become zero.
And when you use that number in division
or log,
you will get infinities and overflow can
be caused by learning rates being too
high or by some kind of bad training
example that you haven't sanitized or a
pre processed.
But um,
the debugger should help you find the
root cause of that kind of issue is
more,
more quickly.
So the TF debugger is a command line
tool.
It's nice,
it's a low footprint.
You can use it if you have access to a
computer only via a terminal,
but obviously it's going to be even
nicer if we can debulk the tensorflow
models in a graphical user interface.
So I'm excited to tell you about a
feature of tensorflow that's upcoming.
So it's called tensor board director
plugin or visual graphical debugger for
tensorflow.
So it's not included in the latest
release of
has low,
which is one point five,
but it's coming in the next release one
point six.
It's available for preview in Natalie's.
So,
um,
you can copy and paste the code from
here,
install those nightly builds of
tensorflow and the cancer board.
And you can use the feature.
So after you have installed these
packages,
you can run a command.
So I'm all the code in my slides are
copy paste to execute that Calabasas.
Yeah.
So these are about the main features of
upcoming tool.
So,
um,
if you're interested,
please copy and paste these code and to
try it out.
This slide here is just a reminder of
the main features in here.
Um,
okay.
So as,
as um,
summary,
we see that there are two ways to
represent the machinery models in
tensorflow,
um,
or in any deep learning framework either
as a data structure or as a program.
If it's a data structure then you will
get symbolic execution and symbolic
execution is good for deployments,
distribution and optimization.
And if it's a program that you will get
eager execution,
it's good for prototyping,
debugging,
and a writing control flow structures
and it's also easier to learn.
And the country in terms of law supports
both modes so you can pick and choose
the best mode for you depending on your
need.
And,
uh,
um,
we also went over tens of load debugger,
both the command line interface and the
browser version,
which will help you debug your model
more efficiently.
So with that,
I'm going to thank my colleagues on the
Google brain team both in the amount of
new headquarters and here in Cambridge.
Um,
she and Mahima are the two collaborators
with me on the cancer board,
debugger plugging project.
And a tensorflow is an open source
project.
There have been over 1000 contributors
like you who have fixed bugs and
contributing new features.
So if you see any interesting things
that you can do,
feel free to contribute to tensorflow on
get hub.
If you have questions,
please email me.
And if you see any bugs or feature
requests about tensorflow or 10 boards,
you can fall on the bugs on these links.
Thank you very much for your attention.
The question.